this is one of those perfect examples
where it's kind of its kind of a little
bit death my notation right because like
there's not much there but I don't I've
got nothing to grab one to migrate won't
even start okay but but if you remember
back to what notation means it's not
that hard to climb back in and access
the question okay so it's a begin with
classic classic math teacher
mathematician strategy right
I just think about what does a simpler
version of this base to free time
suppose I said this okay so that's much
simpler okay I can work with that
what that means is well what this means
is is the modulus of Z that's the
distance to Z is equal to one okay now
hopefully you can see it okay what if I
have a finite complex plane okay which
complex Nova is exactly one unit away
from the origin right so a second this
happened I rubbed off my complex women
father this all a bunch of numbers that
are one unit from the origin right for
example what is one unit from the origin
X negative one is one unit from the
origin
i- i they all one unit from the origin
okay
in fact this equation traces out the
locus of points that represents all
equidistant from the origin specifically
their wandering away okay so every
complex number that i draw one here is
one unit from Eurasia okay with that so
this this is my heads up to this you can
contend with that so so done right but I
don't have this to buy so to understand
what's going on if they won't
what's different between this and is and
how does it mean I have to interpret
this geometrically different okay now
there's two ways that I can go about
this one is easy to see but doesn't do
much insight the other way is hard to
see but as you will discover is rather
more useful
so I'm going to get rid of this solution
now that you have in your brain okay so
you have the general idea it's going to
have something to do don't obviously got
a lot of comment but now I'm going to
forget that it's not the actual question
now again I'm trying to tackle what's a
simpler problem than that yeah I've
already tried one let's try another
Avenue right so if I think about what's
the difference between this number and
this number
remembering that complex numbers can be
thought of as points this and this are
two different points in the plane
so for instance if I come in here and I
say well like this zip is some arbitrary
example where is n minus 1 in this
diagram I think we looked at this
briefly this morning to K minus 1 that's
a real number which direction is it it's
to the left so there's n minus 1 okay so
the modulus of Z is this line here this
length and the modulus is n minus 1 this
length and I want it to be 1 okay now
this is one way of thinking about it but
it tends it to be not actually that
usual like where can I go from here now
right like I start my circle idea but
I'm kind of stuck Stirling where's my
next step ok well he's my next step I
can think of moving my complex number
what's our left right and measuring the
origin ok that's fine but to borrow -
borrow mine Stein's kind of way of
thinking right why do I have to move
this point right I'd have to just meet
that point I have another options
instead of moving the thing that I'm
observing instead I can move my point of
reference so do you see measuring
from the origin trusses misery visions
at minus 1 from the origin is the same
comparison as measuring Z not from the
origin
do you see that this is another equally
valid way to find the absolute values n
minus 1 aha you see what's going one
down right so both of these so if these
are true ok but this is far more
powerful right because now what this
means is uh huh
he's my center now ok
I've adjusted my frame of reference
because I knew what it meant when this
was equal to 1 it was a circle
it was a round origin this is also a
circle but it's not around the origin
anymore it's being shifted one unit to
the right right
ok now let's think about this right ever
let me draw something like let's see did
I get it right does this work
ok let's pick out a point and see if
this makes sense ok so one point like
this ok so it let's call this one what
is it - I know that this distance here
is one right because that's how I define
this red Sun here are you ok with that
so therefore if that distance is 1 then
by definition where is Z 2 minus 1 is it
at here move to the left one unit right
so it's gonna be like
so it's still going to be incident on
what's its difference between origin
it's gonna be there okay now my problem
of course is that my my scale is
completely off if I in fact know that
I've moved one youth to the right and
this is the radius right in fact a
better diagram a to scale diagram would
look like it never crossed this okay so
I was a bit misleading because I was
doing this all in general yeah yeah good
good good
it was because it was because I just
drew a circle right but now you can see
now think about anywhere on here think
about you now I know what the radius of
this circle is right so for example that
point that I actually know exactly what
its coordinates are right is it's right
so for that point let's test out neon
beyond modulus and back rygart modulus a
2 minus 1 which is the modulus of 1
which is 1 right right how about what at
this point I know this points on the
element on the circle as well that's 0
so I'll test that up the modulus is your
minus 1 is the modulus of minus 1 which
is 1 right okay hold on let's push a
little further I know at that point is
that it's 1 plus y yes okay so what's
the modulus of 1 plus I take away 1
that's it - 1 isn't it well one take
away 1 or cancel it so I just get the
one by which you bet is 1 right so do
you see this is the locus of points that
is equidistant they're all 1 but they're
not around the origin anymore I have
been in horizontally shifted I'd be
translated actually a better way of
saying